Ya.
Kalau kita lihat kemampuan yang ada hari ini, menurut saya itu
juga pertanyaan yang sangat penting, yaitu
apa roadmap-nya, seberapa jauh
sistem-sistem ini bisa berkembang
dan seberapa kompleks
circuit yang bisa kita jalankan
dan untuk itu kita sudah mengembangkan metrik yang sangat penting
yang disebut quantum volume
kadang kamu mungkin membaca atau mendengar di media populer
tentang jumlah qubit, kamu tahu
sebagai ukuran kemajuan
terus terang saya bilang
jumlah qubit dalam mesin saja bukanlah
ukuran kemajuan yang baik
kemajuan perlu diukur dari
tingkat kompleksitas circuit yang bisa kamu jalankan
qubit dan mesin-mesin bagus ini belum sempurna hari ini
dan ada error yang muncul akibat keterikatan
sistem dengan dunia luar
justru kekuatan dari qubit-qubit ini
yaitu entanglement dan sifat-sifatnya
itulah yang membuatnya sekaligus kuat
dan rentan terhadap gangguan
dan koneksi ke dunia luar
jadi kamu perlu menurunkan tingkat error
sambil menambah jumlah qubit
itulah yang digambarkan di sini
yang benar-benar ingin kamu lakukan adalah bergerak secara diagonal
dan quantum volume adalah ukuran yang menggabungkan
kedua metrik tersebut beserta beberapa pertimbangan penting lainnya